bonjour nicolas guilbert merci de
répondre à nos questions en direct ce
matin sur arte france olivier véran l'a
dit hier soir lors de son point-presse
fermer les écoles à je cite des
conséquences lourdes pour le
développement des enfants et sur le
quotidien des parents comment est-ce que
vous jugez l'argumentaire du ministre de
la santé
bonjour et bien tout simplement que le
gouvernement reste sur scène une ligne
libérale une ligne confuse ils ne font
rien
c'est un gouvernement vous tuez preuve
de mollesse n'est pas en répétant le mot
fort et renforcées qu'ils montreront
leurs forces
monsieur macro hiver nous a servi un
discours insipide rempli de jargon
libéral d'entreprises comme si la france
était une entreprise non nous ne sommes
pas des produits
nous ne sommes pas là pour faire
fonctionner sa start up nation cela
garde ne roulons pas nous ce que nous
demandons depuis le mois de juin c'est
d'être en demi groupe pour protéger le
pays pour protéger les familles pour
protéger nos élèves et nous protéger
nous personnels d'éducation
rien n'a été fait vous l'a répété à cor
et à cri rien n'est fait donc s'il faut
faire une greffe pour se faire entendre
pourquoi pas c'est une possibilité nous
les stylos rouges nous allons tout
simplement décidé de porter plainte
contre monsieur blanc car devant la cour
de justice de la république pour mise en
danger délibérée de la vie d'autrui
délibéré parce que comme le dit le
professeur comme de la salpêtrière
l'addition sur france info il ya deux
jours le gouvernement savait que les
écoles étaient des clusters comme santé
publique france le disait régulièrement
et a volontairement laissé les
établissements ouverts sans
distanciation sociales jusqu'à
aujourd'hui seul lycée et pas tous en
novembre sous notre pression sont passés
en demi groupe vraiment de mauvaise
grâce monsieur blanc caire refuse tout
amendement toute possibilité tout
protocole réel on n'a toujours aucun
protocole à l'école des nouveaux
protocoles des renforts de protocoles
sont à l'étude selon olivier ferrand
hier c'est quoi ces protocoles justement
c'est ce que vous
demandez peut-être non on le demande
depuis huit mois
donc ce n'est pas c'est plus de la
lenteur c'est plus de la bêtise je sais
même plus ce que c'est à ce niveau là
ils attendent quoi en fait on est déjà
en ile-de-france à 750 % les l'a donc le
taux d'incidents sein du coc vide chez
les 10-19 ans mais qu'est ce qu'ils
attendent
ils attendent qu'il y ait des morts chez
les jeunes ils attendent que ces jeunes
sud des personnes plus âgées n'ont pas
volontairement parce qu'ils répandent le
virus et scénario vous ça veut dire que
c'est quand on trie des patients à
l'hôpital par exemple les gens qui vont
avoir un problème cardiaque y voir une
maladie autre que le call it vont mourir
à cause de ces décisions
gouvernementales
monsieur macron et son gouvernement font
preuve de légèreté et son criminel dans
leur manière de gérer cette situation
sanitaire nous c'est pour cela nous
justement nous portons plainte contre
monsieur blanc cadre estimant que c'est
quelqu'un qui fait preuve de légèreté et
il a une attitude criminelle qu'il doit
être responsable de ce qu'il fait un
chef doit être responsable il ne peut
pas voir que des privilèges être
entretenue par la population française
d'un côté parader dans tous les médias
et ensuite essayer des gens mourir parce
qu'il a une espèce d'agenda libéral ne
nous intéresse pas qu'ils n'apportent
rien à personne mais vous ne comprenez
quand même que si les écoles sont
fermées les enfants ne sont pas gardés
et du coup les parents ne peuvent pas
travailler et c'est l'économie qui s'en
trouve impacté mais l'économie est déjà
impacté l'économie réelle est détruite
monsieur m'a compte des fonds que la
finance enfin les restaurants sont
détruits les bars ont détruit commun de
vêtements sont détruites sous sa seule
mesure ce qui se passe dans les trois
nouvelles département aujourd'hui c'est
quoi on ferme les boutiques de vêtements
c'est tout il n'ya aucun confinement
donc oui l'économie est en partie un
prière sorte qu'elle n'excluait pas
d'autres mesures de nouvelles mesures
dans les prochaines semaines ça veut
dire quoi par exemple la fermeture des
écoles c'est envisageable selon vo ça va
se faire nous nous l'appelons de nos
jeux à la longue puisque rien n'a été
fait avant n'a plus le choix
mais simplement c'est un gouvernement
qui ne fait que réagir ils subissent ils
sont faibles
ils sont en échec constant ils font tout
pour le rester ils font tout pour que la
france est une position honteuse dont
dans ce qui se passe j'ai honte moi pour
les vaccins qui sont une véritable
catastrophe août pour la gestion de la
crise sanitaire honte pour l'école en
général
peut-être qu'ils feront enfin quelque
chose mais ce sera trop tard dans tous
les cas est ce qu il ne discrimine et
l'école pour sauver l'hôpital
on ne sacrifie pas l'école nous voulons
rappeler nous les stylos rouges que
pendant tout le confinement nous avons
travaillé
monsieur blanc coeur essaie de faire
croire que le distanti elle n'est pas du
travail
et bien si je vous assure que c'est du
travail d'ailleurs les enseignants font
du télétravail la moitié de leur temps
et depuis toujours donc dire que le
télétravail n'est pas du travail c'est
c'est comme ça ça veut pas dire que
c'est parfait ça ne baisse c'est génial
le télétravail passé le mieux qu'on peut
dans cette situation sanitaire
oui c'est difficile pour tout le monde
non ce n'est pas idéal mais pour sauver
des vies ça vaut le coup de faire du
téléenseignement d'être à distance un
jour sur deux et peut-être totalement
pour quelques semaines l'été les parents
gardent leurs enfants ils peuvent bien
le faire maintenant faire un effort eux
mêmes être en télétravail nous savons
très bien que dans nombre d'entreprises
privées
les salariés refusent le télétravail
soit leur chef soit les salariés eux
mêmes par caprice il ya un moment où la
réunion zoom exactement comme nous nous
faisons l'interview cela peut se faire
par un zoom justement lieu de se faire
en présentiel
le travail peut se faire à la maison on
peut garder un enfant hormis pour les
plus petits il n'y a pas de problème et
je rappelle c'est très important que
nous les stylos rouges depuis le mois de
juin nous appelons aussi est-ce que les
mairies prennent en charge et les écoles
peut-être les enfants qui ne peuvent pas
du tout être gardés par leurs parents
attention qui ne peuvent réellement pas
pas par caprice encore une fois tout le
monde doit faire un effort cnr
questionnement c'est plus important que
le travail
dernière question par rapport à la
vaccination emmanuel macron qui s'est
déplacé 1 valenciennes mardi il a appelé
à une vaccination pour les enseignants
pour la fin ou la mi-avril des
enseignants profession je cite exposé en
ce moment sa sémantique est ce que vous
croyez une campagne de vaccination
ciblée par par métier à risques et ça a
quand même dans le bon sens cette
annonce mans alors on verra bien je n'y
crois pas du tout nous n'y croyons
absolument pas puisque les couacs sur le
vaccin ont été multiples reconnaître que
nous sommes à risques c'est dans ce
cas-là reconnaître on nous met en danger
dans ce cas là nous avons raison porté
plainte et monsieur mac on soutiendra
toute autre plainte
nous l'appelons même à tige rejoindre si
elles le souhaitent un contre monsieur
blanc car pas de problème voilà enfin
bon
nous nous appelons aussi à ce que les
enseignants qui le souhaitent soient
vaccinés parce qu'effectivement nous
sommes en première ligne nous sommes à
40 centimètres les uns des autres et des
élèves
il n'y a aucune distanciation sociales
jusqu'à aujourd'hui dans l'intégralité
des écoles maternelles primaires
collèges de france dont les facs et les
lycées ça a été le cas jusqu en octobre
novembre
il n'y avait aucune distanciation
sociale rien n'a été fait c'est criminel
je répète que c'est pour cela que nous
portons plainte devant la cjr contre
monsieur blanc caire le message est
passé merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions nicolas beer je rappelle que
vous êtes enseignant et membre du
collectif les stylos rouges heures